habitante d'orgeval christelle lemoine
va participer à la première édition du
tracking gazelle avec seulement une
carte et une boussole et des coordonnées
géographiques
elle devra rallier chaque jour plusieurs
balises c'est une course d'orientation
mais ce n'est pas une course de rapidité
il s'agit en fait véritablement
d'essayer de faire le moins de
kilomètres possibles donc il faut
trouver via tout le chemin qu'on aura
balisé de toute la journée
la distance la plus courte possible ce
track 100 % féminin organisé par mayenga
une agence événementielle et sportive
est aussi 100% solidaire 5 euros seront
reversés au secours populaire pour
chaque balise trouvé par une équipe
puisque l' aventure se fait à trois
christelle est donc accompagné d'emilie
et de laurence qui habitent en région
parisienne et qui travaille avec
christelle quand elle a su que c'était
un trek
elle a pensé à moi parce qu'elle sait
que j'aime le trek voilà donc le trek la
marche le côté un peu non confortable de
l'endroit aussi le désert est
intéressant et puis le fait de
bivouaquer pour s'entraîner les deux
jeunes femmes font des randonnées
christelle vient entre trois à cinq fois
par semaine dans le bois d'abbécourt à
orgeval l'avantagent de cette oreille
c'est que ça nous permet d'avoir
plusieurs passages avec quelques
dénivelés dont celui ci ce qui nous
permet justement de nous entraîner à
démonter un petit peu compliqué alors
évidemment c'est pas un environnement
sableux mariée et mère de trois enfants
cette quarantenaire avait déjà participé
au rallye automobile en 2019
une expérience qui l'a beaucoup marqué
c'est une aventure qui est passionnante
dans tous les sens du terme
c'est un beau dépassement de soi
incroyable c'est vraiment pas facile ça
va être physique
après ça va être aussi beaucoup mentale
puisque la fatigue le stress
malgré cela christelle tient à
participer de nouveau à ce rallye cette
fois ci à pied les trois jeunes femmes
sont encore à la recherche de sponsors
pour financer leur aventure